the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
how are you guys doing I came across a
very inspiring very powerful video of a
young boy who wants to send a message to
all of us fromaz let's take a look at it
and respond in
[Music]
kind
for
[Music]
now for me this is
extremely touching and actually a very
powerful Testament of the faith of Islam
that it can enter the heart of a young
boy like this the resilience the sheer
resilience that that
boy
possesses when he's on the rubble that
was left behind by the IDF is a
testament to the power and the strength
of Al
Islam because Islam the religion of Al
Islam is a
religion of
optimism it's a religion of of
Hope and even in the worst situations we
are told by Allah subhana wa ta'ala in
the Quran to be patient to be
strong Allah subhana wa tala for example
mentions
[Music]
in
that we will certainly try
you that we will surely and certainly
try
you
fear
hunger
enus a
depreciation in Monies and lives human
lives Allah is telling us that's going
to happen he said that in the
Quran and give Glad Tidings to those who
are
patient the ones who when a Calamity
strikes them they
say that certainly we belong to Allah as
certainly we will turn to Allah that
those are the ones who have been given
blessings from Allah and those are the
ones who are rightly
guided but Allah subhah wa ta'ala
also says the following to us in the
Quran this is so powerful because a lot
of the verses in the Quran they take on
a new life with
calamities they make us think about the
meaning and purpose of life in a
different way and of course the Quran
for those non-muslims I know watching is
the book of guidance for us it's what
gives us this strength it's what gives
us this
resilience Allah says in the Quran the
same
Surah
[Music]
[Laughter]
or did you think that you are going to
enter Jenna that you are going to enter
paradise and the calamities that those
who came before you you did not yet face
that they fac travesties and calamities
and they were shaken so much so that the
prophet among them
said when is the help of
God alas the help of God is
near
alas the help of God is
near and this sub
this verse is connected with one in and
this is a very important if you want to
know what's going on in at the moment
and what is closest to resembling in the
life of the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam it is actually
theab it is actually chapter 33 of the
Quran the Confederates when there there
were Confederates that were
confederating and allying against the
prophet so much so that they they dug
trenches around the perimeter
of the Medina of of the city so that
they could stop the offensive from
coming in Subhan Allah very very
interesting very similar and in that
Batel is mentioned
in in chapter 33 of the
Quran
[Music]
this verse inah bak and this verse in
are connected in fact they're connected
by even the MU like and others and and
and all these they say they're connected
that when the Confederates so when the
Muslims saw the Confederates they say
this is what Allah and the messenger
promised for us and Allah and the
messenger spoke the
truth and this whole situation which is
actually the onslaught this is what the
situation is that the Muslims were being
attacked in one small
City that that whole situation it
increased their IM it increased their
tasim it increased their submissiveness
and increased their faith so you see
that situation there which was an attack
on the Muslim people and attack on the
Muslim people increased the faith of
these like that young boy that you just
saw in the beginning of this video why
because they were already pre-worn by
Allah they expect it calamities are part
of life and it doesn't have to be a
Calamity in Gaza you're going to face a
Calamity I'm going to face a Calamity
the strong one amongst us is the one who
can be patient in that and isn't it
ironic sometimes that we find people in
the west Muslims and other parts of the
world who because they've been weakened
because their mind is so weak that
they're watching it and they can't
handle even watching it but then you
have a boy like this coming forward and
saying that this is what I believe in
this is what I believe in this is what I
believe I've watched hundreds if not
really honestly thousands of these
videos maybe hundreds so I don't
exaggerate of these people in Palestine
I've yet to see one person despairing
from the mercy of Allah I've yet to see
I all I see is people
coming saying Allah is sufficient for us
as a disposer of Affairs saying Allah
Akbar saying Allah is the greatest now
these people on the right and other
people are trying to attack it and call
it a terroristic chant allahar just
means Allah is the greatest saying all
kinds of
words the verse I've just mentioned or a
part of it which is that we belong to
Allah and we will return to him this is
what I see happening and why because the
faith of Islam brings meaning to
travesty just as it brings meaning to
good times and just as it bring brings
meaning to life
itself and this is a practical case
study example of how that is the case
you can see how it's comforting the
people how it's strengthening the people
how it gives them
advantage
allahar and these people are spending
Millions actually probably billions of
pounds trying to attack effectively
trying to attack Muslim people through
media and through uh military Warfare
and so on but that's not going to help
is it
Allah even promises that to us in the
Quran Allah says in the
[Music]
Quran
[Laughter]
that those
individuals those people from the
disbelievers put
money
so that they can stop the path to Allah
subhana
tala so they will pay more and more
money and then after that it's going to
be a regret for
them then they will be
defeated yes they will be defeated
well and those who have
disbelieved will go will be collected
together in the Hellfire and this is
interesting
here that Allah he wants to
differentiate the impure from the pure
from the
good and to collect together
the effectively the impurities are
collected
together and then who'll collect it
together accumulate it and aggregate it
together
put it into the Hellfire and those are
the losers this is something beautiful
in our religion Allah tells us exactly
what's going to happen What To Expect
and how to deal with it that's why I
invite everybody to Islam the religion
of purpose meaning and
power hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a d our Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more